hey guys it's justine and today we're
unboxing the brand new samsung galaxy
s21 phones
we have the samsung galaxy s21 ultra 5g
and the s21 5g samsung released
three new phones this past week and they
also came out with these new smart tags
and the galaxy buds pro we have two of
the three to check out the other phone
that they announced was the s21 plus 5g
which is basically just a little bit
larger of a phone than the s21
today's just gonna be a quick unboxing
and then later on in the week i'm gonna
have a full review of both of these
phones
can you guys believe that it's 20 21
like i'm still kind of processing that
this is the first phone unboxing
of the new year let's start with the s21
the one thing that you're gonna notice
is there's not a charging brick
in the box if i roll my eyes
any harder they're going to fall out of
my head because do we remember
not too long ago when everyone was like
armageddon i can't believe apple didn't
put
a charger in the box we knew this was
gonna happen it's like not a surprise so
are you shocked no am i shocked
absolutely not the colors though of
these new samsung devices
are so freaking beautiful oh my gosh
it's the purple
this is the phantom violet i love what
they're calling all of the colors
phantom the one that you're gonna notice
on the camera bump is they
did sort of like this integrated design
so they kind of took the entire
camera bump and made it a part of the
camera so it's one
very smooth seamless design so there's
no
kind of separation between the camera
pump it's like actually a part of the
phone
this purple is nice they also came out
with the phantom black
silver and then there's a gold and red
and will take a few more weeks to come
in and then the s21 ultra comes annie
phantom black and the phantom silver
there's also a phantom titanium navy and
brown that's made order and ships in
four to five weeks
the back is way less smudgy than
previous phones they kind of have like
this hazy glass
finish so it's a really nice
really really nice matte finish
i love this purple obviously i love the
color pink but i think that i
actually this is probably the phone that
i would choose
there's anything else in the box like a
charging brick that is non-existent
which is fine well there's no charging
brick we do have a very nice usb-c
cable have you ever seen one of these no
you have it
first time welcome to the world of usbc
of course our sim card ejector very
important
t-mobile so this is the s21 and this has
a 6.2 inch amoled dynamic 120hz display
that's
1300 nits of brightness it has 8 gigs of
ram 128 gigs
or 256 gigs of storage it has a triple
camera setup on the back it has the
ultra wide
and wide 12 megapixels and a 64
megapixel telephoto
and the front camera is 10 megapixels
this has a 4 000 milliamp battery a
fingerprint scanner
and ip68 rating now the s21 plus is
almost identical to the s21
but it does have a 6.7 inch display and
a 4 800 milliamp battery so you are
going to be having a larger display
and also longer battery life with the
plus now do we open
up this s21 ultra
baby i have stuff all over this desk i'm
trying to be clean and it's
not really working i've already seen
pictures
and videos of this phantom black and i'm
so excited about it they made this huge
deal about the phantom black how they
went through this crazy process to try
to make the perfect black
and i'm hoping that in person it's as
good as it looks in photos i'm so hyped
i'm so hyped get ready for it
oh yeah oh yeah this does not disappoint
so they weren't joking about how nice
this camera bump
actually is it looks so good having it
actually integrated into the camera so
there isn't this big notch or cutout
around the side i mean obviously like
that's a little excessive
you can't really get away with that
unless you made this entire back
this thick and nobody wants that so this
has a 6.8 inch dynamic qhd 120 hertz
adaptive display with brightness up to 1
500 nits
i have a field monitor that i use when
i'm out shooting with my actual regular
camera like this
and that is a 1500 nits monitor and it's
really incredible because of the screen
brightness i'm actually able to see
out in the brightness of a sunny day so
i love the fact that the screen
brightness is
pretty bright so you have two different
options you have a 12 and 16 gig ram
option but if you decide to get the 12
gig model you can
get either 128 or 256 gigs of storage
but if you get the 16 gig model only
have the option of getting 512 gigs of
storage so
that is kind of give or take if you want
the 512 you're then gonna have to get
the 16 gigs of ram what will i ever do
with those four gigs extra of ram
maybe play xbox games like maybe halo
the front camera is 40 megapixels and it
has a new quad camera set up here on the
back
with this all-new enhanced 108 megapixel
sensor
you'll have a 12 megapixel ultra wide
108 megapixel wide
and these new dual telephoto zoom lenses
that's 10 megapixels plus there's an
additional laser autofocus sensor this
is obviously going to help so much with
focusing and also doing portrait mode
photos
very excited to test that out with a 5
000 milliamp battery you're obviously
going to get much better battery life
over the s20 and s21 plus
and this is actually one of the first s
devices that has s pen support
obviously the notes have the built-in
pens whereas this one does not
but the fact that this has support for
the s-pen or the s-pen pro that they
also showed in the unpacked event
is pretty exciting because i love being
able to use that
and now that's just one more added
option and another reason to get the
ultra as far as pricing is concerned the
s21 starts at 799 the s21 plus
999 and the s21 ultra is starting at
11.99 another cool thing about the ultra
is you're gonna be able to shoot 4k
60 frames on every single lens normally
one of the things that's always kind of
upsetting is they kind of lack on the
front-facing camera so the fact that yes
you are able to shoot 4k 60
on the front-facing and every other lens
on this camera
hyped about that of course both of these
phones
shoot 8k video which when we kind of
just wrap our
minds around that phone's shooting 8k
you're also going to be getting the 100x
zoom
i'm sure you guys remember last year on
the s20 when they were hyping up the
100x zoom
yes it's it's a novelty because let's be
real quality was not the best
but they have done some things here in
the s21 ultra to improve that using ai
and additional stabilization some of the
demos that i saw it actually looked like
it was improved so
that'll be something that we're gonna
test out as soon as i take this out in
the field in the field like am i going
in a field like why people say in the
field
now that i'm saying it out loud and
hearing myself say it maybe i will go in
the field
you're also able to do these 8k video
snaps so if you are shooting in 8k
you're gonna be able to get a 33
megapixel
basically a screenshot from that ak
video they've also enhanced the single
take and they have this new director
view
with a vlogger view option so you can be
filming on the front and back camera at
the same time which
we've talked about this before using
various apps on the iphone
so this is kind of exciting i must say
that i haven't really ever used it that
much
but the fact that this is something that
you can do i think there is a lot of
cool implementation to be able to film
both front and back
but also i feel like a lot of the times
that i probably would have used this
is when i was traveling and that's the
whole world shut down i really just
never really needed it also
we have the new buds pro which these
look really cool they're talking about a
really cool feature where you can do
multi mic recording with the buds pro so
you're not only able to record
the ambient sound but you're able to
record your voice as well so that's
going to be
something that's kind of neat take a
little look at these i would also love
to know from you guys like what would
you like
to see me do with these like should i
maybe go on like a little kovid safe
road trip with it
in the field do a little testing
those look so good look at that
look at that that's gonna match that
phantom
black what else is in here oh another
cable
just what we need what's this this is
the smallest little box
i've ever seen look at that look at
these this
is small wow it's so it's a little
it's so cute oh so many goodies
you guys hyped for 20 21 tech
i'm not gonna lie and then the last
thing that we have here is one of the
samsung smart tags
i love things that can help me find my
things
so this will connect to your phone and i
also loved all of the
integrations that they were talking
about also in unpacked with all of your
smart home devices being able to unlock
your car with your phone so i'm sure you
guys have all seen
tile trackers before so this is
something very
very similar check that out i was
watching my sister's video and she
dropped this on the floor and then she
couldn't find it she's like well i can
use my phone to find it because that's
basically what you're supposed to do
find the tile tracker tag i'm wondering
if
apple was just waiting for samsung to
release theirs
so that they can be like oh here's ours
i've been feeling that's probably what
they were doing because those air tags
have been rumored for so long like at
this point
do we even want them anymore yeah the
answer is of course
yes we do i'm gonna put this on
something and then i'm gonna have
tyler or jenna hide it from me and then
i'm gonna go find it doesn't that sound
like a 2021 version of hide and seek
sounds fun to me
i also didn't turn on these two lights
purposely because i knew we were doing
like a phantom black color today
so i wanted it to be a little moody okay
so here we go this
is kicking off the year just right
we've got our s21 ultra
and our s21 i'm gonna set these up
and prepare for my full review again if
there's anything that you guys would
like to see me do with this
please leave it in the comments below
because i would love to integrate your
comments into my actual review
and if you have any questions also leave
those not gonna lie i'm getting kind of
bored
of the sort of same routine that i feel
like i find myself in when i'm doing
reviews
so i'd love to hear from you guys like
what do you want to see
what would you like me to test i think
maybe it would be kind of fun to sort of
bring your comments into the actual
review video i don't know i want to try
some new things this year i know last
year was kind of interesting because we
really didn't have many options like i
couldn't really
we still really can't go anywhere or do
anything but i want to find
a nice safe way to take this out and
test
and not have to be around any people i
will see you guys in the comments
and now oh god i can't wait to freaking
test this out
this oh this looks so good i'm hyped
i'll see you later bye
[Music]